[Musique]
enfin moi je suis directeur je ne
prendrai pas je vous dis cash je
prendrai parfois il peut être compétent
il paye ce qu'il veut je ne prendrai pas
parce que ben c'est il faut une la
neutralité sur le corps par rapport à un
enfant qui qui arrive dans le monde qui
découvre qui apprend non je pense pas
que ça soit correcte j'ai rien contre
les tatouages ans après les personnes
font ce qu'elles veulent mais en dehors
du milieu scolaire
[Musique]
on
au début enfin quand je fais tatouer en
fait je me fais tatouer très égoïstement
pour moi je ne pense pas au reste mais
avec le recul je me rends compte que ça
les enfants qui me voient ils apprennent
également sur la tolérance et sur le
respect des autres et peut-être que en
étant comme je suis sans le vouloir mais
en étant comme je suis rien qu'à être au
contact avec les enfants c'est peut être
que quand ils seront adultes qui sont il
ya un peu plus de chance qu'il ne soit
pas raciste qui ne soit pas homophobes
qu'il ne le regarde pas les handicapés
comme des bêtes de foire
donc je me dis que c'est positif moi je
trouve ça un peu inquiétant que les gens
aient commencé à s'arrêter à l'apparence
physique mais ce que ce qui est étonnant
d'ailleurs c'est que c'était surtout des
parents qui s'arrête à l'apparence
physique parce que maintenant c'est vrai
qu'on éduque de plus en plus à pas
s'arrêter à l'apparence physique et à
plus aller chercher les gens on est de
plus en plus dans les écoles
oklahoma me suis dit que c'est comme si
moi je me mettais un tatouage fait pas
de free je vais devenir méchant un
tatouage à son courage sa change pas le
caractère et comportements si la
première fois que de réviser sur tous
ces yeux qui m'ont fait peur ban a
series une noire et marron s'est pas tué
bah si tu t'habitues au petit à petit
battu à d'habitués et après la bi tube
battu pourra faire de ton mieux
l'abattoir